did you hear Yanni or Laurel I heard
Yanni this would be a great opportunity
to use the Google cloud speech API to
see if your suspicions are correct
the speech API allows you to send audio
and receive a text transcription from
the speech-to-text api service learning
how to use this API is is easier than
you might have thought in fact you
couldn't learn how to use it in about 15
minutes in quick labs and no you do not
need a Google cloud platform account or
project to try this for yourself an
account project and associated resources
are provided to you as part of the quick
lab in this lab you will create a file
for the request to the speech API you'll
then see the transcript value return to
speech API so text transcription of your
audio file the confidence value
indicates how sure the API is that is
accurately transcribed your audio and
just like that you've created a speech
API request the speech API supports both
synchronous and asynchronous speech to
text transcription in this example you
sent it a complete audio file but you
can also use the sync recognized method
to perform streaming speech to text
transcription while the user is still
speaking quick labs is an online
hands-on lab library available 24 hours
a day seven days a week with more than
150 labs on every cloud topic from intro
to expert level each lab helps you learn
a new skill in about 30 minutes using
google cloud when you're ready
use this link to take the lab we just
went through today and when you're ready
to sign up for DCP use this link to
apply a three hundred dollar credit to
your account we want to hear from you
every week we'll answer a question from
our viewers so let us know what's on
your mind in the comments below
you
[Music]